all these paparazzi
did you hear that Craig Hamilton the
verticals
Gary Conover just say something's
actually sexy
Thanks do something silly silly yeah I
wanted to say something sexy though all
right what's your sexy thing something
sexy yeah all right say something
nostalgic very good improv that's Todd
Smith check out his channel he's what he
does when everyone's gonna be recording
Oliver Stone and Joseph gordon-levitt
how did according everyone who's
recording
I wondered how you thought how you were
going to tell this story I had no idea I
got more and more interested I went to
Moscow to meet him in January of 2014 we
deepened our conversations over the next
months they returned twice and in June
we started my co-writer Karen
Fitzgerald's and I started working on
the screenplay having talked to him and
got and realized that he was cooperating
we were getting an Inside Story
this was very exciting so he's still
haven't solved how to do it to us it was
a rubric you too much
a lot of technical technical information
a lot of know was known about his
relationship with Lindsay who becomes a
factor in this very point in fact so
that grew out of our talks I ended up
went back nine times like I went to
Moscow I'm cured went three times but we
ended up talking about and getting a lot
of details and in bits and pieces so we
decided in this summer to go with a
linear structure person they start at
the beginning like like we did like I
did on the board on the fourth of July
in 1989 which was tell the story
straight
I've tracked you go with his beginnings
as a soldier as a young civilian CIA and
and so forth lead to this first posting
imperil posting in Geneva and then
parallel that story with the Hong Kong
story which opens a film and ends up the
climax being the release of the
information so we add not to dwell on
the escape or anything like that but
really well in the first part of the
story how he became the man he did and
why and is it harder to play somebody
this not only current I wouldn't say was
hard to know it gives you so much to go
on
it's really inspiring and you know my
favorite performances usually are the
actors who disappear into their
characters you don't see that known
person on the screen would just see the
person in the story and when when I have
someone like Edward Snowden who I can
study who I can listen to who I can I
wouldn't disagree met him
Oliver Robbie on one of his trips to
Moscow it gives me so much to go on to
really create a character that's
different from myself because that's to
me that's what's so one of the things
that's so fun about acting is becoming
what about the sure other once months
going to tell you guys another story
it was true we don't have to okay I'm
happy to wait when when when Ed and I
first sat down actually Lindsay was also
in the room it's a longtime girlfriend
reshaped players in movie Algar was
there with us for the beginning of our
meeting and and we immediately started
talking about what interests
ed the most which is you know
international affairs and politics and
and all of us like don't talk about that
you can read about that asking them how
he sleeps how he eats with it's
quintessential grace that always brings
every situation and but it's really true
that I could read about his positions
and understand him as a political figure
as so many people do but but the value
meeting in face to face was getting to
observe those little nuances how he
walks or talks or eats or sleeves how
each Japan's I didn't observe our
sleeves but I did observe how he yeah
and you know I noticed the first thing I
noticed was I'm just taking all those
prompts and keep telling then you know
there's there's a stereotype that people
who are good on computers are sort of
socially awkward and I was I was
half-expecting that and which was really
just me being guilty were prejudiced and
it turned out not to really be the case
he's it's quite old-fashioned in a way
you know he's from North Carolina where
they put a lot of emphasis on good
manners I think or at least more so than
they do when I'm from in Southern
California and yeah he really was a sort
of a very graceful gentleman
playing Lindsay it's so much more than
just the protagonist well friend you
know it's it's our sort of way of seeing
him as a fully form factor I think so
how did you get to talk to them see did
you read anything about her how did you
prepare to play her high ticket to talk
to Lindsay but not until three months
into production Oliver had no mental
times Joanne met Lindsay Kemble chair of
the co record had as well and so I
really trusted and valued their stories
that they had to share about her and
their observations of her personality
and who she was
since I wasn't able to do that forehand
and then she did have a pretty wide
range of past social media posts
predating 2013 that I sort of
investigated and sifted through because
she's a self portrait photographer
there's a lot of her art online so a big
part of it for me was trying to identify
and capture this enthusiasm and this
extroverted nature that she expressed
through her art and through stories that
they shared but also just trying to keep
it as grounded as well as possible
without without going too far into
trying to 100% recreate who actually
movements emails actually is because I
do
people ready for the first question you
already got a mic
first of all thank you for being here
and thank you for a great movie I have
to follow questions mister selling
there's a line in the movie that
irritated me which says fighting
terrorism is just an excuse for massive
data collection I thought it was a
little bit overstated and we sense that
terrorism is a live issue we Hannity and
Europe as you know pretty bad so
Intelligence Agency need information so
between security and if I may add if we
the future if we get robots coming in
from industry 4.0 digitalization big
time does that mean that analysts will
be quickly in the future robots and we
will have in the future
thank you share the British point of
view on security at all costs I
fundamentally disagree with that view
and there's the quote you mentioned
which is a very
good quote came directly to mr. Sok in
one of his newspaper articles we took it
from that and he obviously believes that
because he's been in that business and
he's what he's talking about there's a
huge waste of resources in tapping
everybody surveilling entire populations
you end up looking for a needle totally
in a haystack truly not only need but
bill Binney shares that point of view he
worked there and he divides into the
original map of worldwide code called
thinthread that program was not used it
was like the Nicholas Cage character
says in the movie a cheap three million
dollar homegrown gorilla type program
and it worked and that was thrown out in
favor of a gigantic three million dollar
project called trailblazer which ended
up we use right after 9/11 and that too
trailblazer has not shown any
demonstrable evidence of results and we
keep asking would show us the results
were true we all believe in stopping
terrorism terrorism is a threat but like
recently fun says in the movie the
United States is behaving like the real
threat is not Isis or the real threat is
Russia China Iran that's what they
really seem to be thinking about
they don't take this terrorism quite as
seriously as you British or thee as that
Europeans do and they should and mr.
Putin takes terrorism very seriously too
so this is a debatable line but we
should have that debate we should have
that debate and
Snowden is called for he hoped that
people would have and we have security
people cute artists we really know
what's going on but we have to do this
for your own protection for your own
protection
well if that's true and we all have to
sign this agreement with government then
give us some evidence of what you're
doing how do I know your system is
really
because in 911 the whole thing broke the
information from the NSA which is
supposed to pick up all the signals
around the world correct in the in 1999
completely goofed it it even followed
the bin Laden signals to the house safe
house in Yemen and Sunnah which they had
they had the phone number and everything
and they sent agents to two of those
people that pass through there ended up
in San Diego as hijackers living there
never think I've never passed over the
FBI FBI if you want to go through the
9/11 Commission and that's just the
surface is a bundle of error a bundle of
error as is and the CIA did do better
but frankly they didn't get through the
precedent so you know let's not talk
about overdoing it let's do our job
correctly let's do the detective work
that's required most of the information
on terrorist actions it's a limited
group of people and they tend to they
tend to communicate it oh they do weak
people in our countries get leads we're
very good at this bread in Germany in
for terrorist back in the 1970s 60s 80's
was in Germany especially in Britain the
IRA we've been through this before all
of a sudden what we have to change all
the ground rules because this is an
emergency according to George Bush and
you're either with us or against us this
is not a solution
this is illogical and hysterical an
overreaction well the other question I
completely don't understand
I think so okay I hope so I hope you're
right
the Germans are crazy about time it
takes 43 minutes to get in the home to
the into the office drive or 52 minutes
and then this driver this car averages
out to the actually 55 minutes because
it's all ordered traffic and you're not
allowed to speed and overtake you're not
allowed to cut two lanes like a lot of
my friends and Jeremy like to do so here
we go the driverless car Society
it won't work I don't think so I think
somebody's going to want to break out or
else become a robot an automated person
you'll feel like a robot I guess I'm
just questioning but how good robots are
so we've really really and why would
they replaces anyone what do you want
why are you in such a rush terrorism is
a human criminal what did you think well
I have to be completely honest that in
2013 when it first happened I really
didn't pay very much attention to it and
it wasn't until a year later when this
job and I remember feeling very excited
that Oliver offered me a job because I'm
such fans but my next thought was okay
wait Edward Snowden I know I've heard
that name
somewhere which ones he and what exactly
did he do I realize I didn't know any of
the specifics you know you hear so much
news I know I'm guilty of this
I only rarely take the time to look in
depth at something and I think it's the
case for a lot of us with with a story
like everyone's know we've kind of heard
something about it but we don't really
know very many of the details that was
me
and and once oliver offered me this job
then then i really looked into it for
myself and i had a lot of learning to do
and at that point after you know well
the first thing i would say that
question is a i wouldn't tell anybody to
take my word for it you know like I just
said it's sort of a complicated story
and I think a lot of people oversimplify
it and I would encourage anyone who's
interested to kind of find out for
themselves I can tell you my personal
opinion which is that you know I
understand why people call him a
criminal that's because he broke the law
when you took classified documents and
delivered them to journalists what the
NSA was also breaking the law and they
were doing it all the time every day in
a really drastic way and and this is a
law that's very important it's in our
Bill of Rights
it's a Fourth Amendment of our
Constitution and they were also lying
about breaking that law one of the
stories that really sucked me in was the
story of this congressional hearing that
took place just if he wants to force
voters were the Director of National
Intelligence James clapper he got up on
the stand and
Congress and swore to tell the truth and
he was axe is the NSA collecting
millions of records on American citizens
and he said no is just an outright lie
but no one could prove that he was lying
until so so ultimately I would love to
work with she's fantastic
actress and she does
haven't seen Don John Bull you wake up
what she brought it down because he
suggests we go see her in Berlin Mart's
and I Morris Forman and I went there we
had better personally in Las Vegas
connections Las Vegas Convention for
hackers in 2012 which is actually
crucial Convention is what Keith
Alexander showed up there he was at NSA
and he was recruiting for the you know
he's who's picking out the best minds
you find getting them to work for the
Pentagon it's interesting because the
anonymous group was there so there was a
you know complete opposites and
Alexander was Major General wears his
stars in front of committees was wearing
civilian clothes and trying to be the
nice guy you know God but they entrust
him when there was interesting it was an
important game of chess justice anecdote
of chess board game between the hackers
and the military guys and the military
guys were wiped out by that drilling it
was like 10 games were going on it same
time at that convention all the stars
this business the buildings at hombre
and Laura had done two very fine
documentaries she was between this movie
we went back to see her she had very
paranoid about anything
and she wouldn't show us any footage
when we asked her to show some footage
she didn't want to which would have
helped us with because you know she were
all snow on the side of this affair
anyway Glen was a much more helpful
state in contact and I had met him
before too he was very kind and very
supportive and he writes the most
intelligent stuff about from the
intercept he likes the most intelligence
on this problem and it's a severe
problem with people not understanding
what happened and what information was
they really don't know they don't really
follow it and I understand why it's
complicated and it's not easy to
understand that but he's done a good job
of explaining it in the intercept along
with many other people at that magazine
I suggest in Germany should be aware of
intercept it's very important to the
survival of some kind of contradiction
to the NSA which is very hard to do when
you gonna have the facts sometimes and
they know and how can we trust them you
know that comes back there essentially
so we and the question goes on and on
and the answer goes drifts into yes they
were and you and me you and McCaskill
from the Guardian was there and I talked
to as well as he was very helpful as
well as the editor of The Guardian woman
played by to enjoy a lead Richardson in
the movie Janine Gibson was very helpful
and this was a big decision to print
this but it could have cost everybody's
career they could have closed down the
Guardian which has a 200 year history
they could have the British rule the
British laws allow for them to close up
and anything they want in the name of
Official Secrets Act and someone that's
something maybe bring up that I think
doesn't get talked about enough that
Oliver just brought up that it was
really these newspapers that made the
decisions of what exactly to publish its
it's a fact that's really worth
repeating that the number of documents
that ever
Snowden delivered to the public at zero
Edward Snowden delivered documents to a
very small select group of establishing
qualified journalists and said I'm not
deciding what goes to the public you
guys decide you make the decisions in
the public interest whereas my awareness
grew enormously this is a world we all
suspected that Bush was up to no good in
the United States I mean it was it was
even a story came out in 2004 vibe from
James risen New York Times about
capacity dropping a legal pasties
wrongly
I came out finally after a year and a
half he was spiked originally by The
Times because it was a month before the
presidential election and mr. Bush got
the story's light so they in the
national interest they buried that
remember that can send me to the neuro
Times published an agave this reason to
be really outraged because Pentagon
Papers cost him a lot of trial and
effort but they were actually a body
money moment through their heroism but
they didn't do that in 2000
for mr. Bush would have lost the
elections my belief would have lost the
election if those papers if what reason
that said he'd come out and he had
enough evidence but he doesn't in
trouble they chased him his career is
practically ruled that we hope he's
going to make a comeback he's a good
reporter but you can't take on the
national security state if you're a
reformer and when you talk to these
people you realize that scary it is for
any reporter was a serious investigator
to go there you get labeled not only
about now the government the United
States is so secretive that anybody who
has lunch with in with a reporter
anybody noseblunt through them has to
get permission from your superior office
or you can see a person socially it's a
strange new system we call it
authoritarian guard my consciousness
their consciousness my consciousness
went up as a result of this that's what
I can say
yeah I knew about and I knew about the
story 2013 he create me impacted my life
I was the last generation to not maybe
use iPhone in high school and little
brothers three years younger and he did
grow up with an iPhone in high school
and even just seeing their remarkable
differences and neither three years
between his generation and mine is
profound there's a lot of there's a lot
of things that separate those two
generations even though three years
wouldn't normally be considered a
generational gap because of Technology
so now I'm thinking about there's always
sort of like a suspicion you know the
big brother and they're watching us in
the one that revealed or I guess said
when the journalist revealed the
information as opposed to them it
validated a lot of suspicions that I had
and it didn't make me paranoid but it
made me made me feel aware and it made
me feel empowered to look at technology
a little bit differently but I hadn't
really taken any action of the steps
that that led to distinct action and
until I grabbed the screenplay for this
movie working on this project was
phenomenal because I learned about the
human the humanity behind Edward Snowden
which is what this movie offers us a lot
of guests have strong opinions about a
man that we know very little about and
our strong opinions are based off the
perspectives and the narratives of
mainstream media and our governments but
they you know they're not formulated or
full formulated opinions because we
didn't have the whole story and now we
have a greater insight into the whole
story I think Oliver was referring to
Mabel it my politics I was yeah you know
one thing that was really an interesting
to me you know in America we have this
it's her election year I was a Bernie
Sanders surrogate and traveled around
with his campaign for this is February
of this year but he enlarged was one of
the only
and it's who talked about Edward Snowden
with you know the point of reverence and
being admired his courage and what he
chose to do and I moving forward now
things cheaper than presidential
candidates that we had it's interesting
as an American to sort of see how this
story even though it affects all
citizens of the world not just America
isn't being talked about largely and I
guess in the debates moving forward that
will be a fascinating topic that I hope
about politics I don't know if you're
aware that there was voting tomorrow in
Switzerland giving permission by law to
the National Intelligence Service to
collect any doubt from everybody in
order to protect freedom and security so
it looks like the predictions are like a
sixty percent yes what's your advice to
do this with
well most people will go with their
government unless they're an open revolt
League just it makes sense the
government's keep repeating it repeating
in terror terrorism fear fear and they
need more laws to catch these people
that's not an evidence it has not been
shown to be true it sometimes it's shown
to be the opposite the more information
they get the less they see they need to
get specific targeted information but
you people will I mean everyone will
vote in the direction of more security
which is insanity you know don't forget
that the Nazis offered the same deal in
the early 1930s there and when they took
power in 1933 I believe it was called
special order number 48 in which they
said the same thing we have to protect
you we must protect your name and then
return well you saw it happen you're
gonna get more security that's what you
think as I said earlier this gentleman I
don't believe it I think it's wonderful
to be voted off that's that's exactly
what didn't happen in the United States
and that's what should be happening so
whether or not master balances is right
or wrong that's a complicated issue I
tend to agree with Oliver I'd like to
see any evidence because the truth is if
there there hasn't been any any
situations where a terrorist plot has
been flourished by these massive
surveillance programs in fact Keith
Alexander who you mentioned earlier at
one point claimed that there had been
1954 cases of terrorism that had been
thwarted by these mass surveillance
programs and was later shown to be lying
and had to publicly admit that he was
lying about that so and this is actually
one thing that I I learned that I didn't
understand before really spending time
but get into this story there's a
difference between mass surveillance and
targeted surveillance so the targeted
surveillance is when they have
you know suspicion that particular
individual might be committing a crime
and they get a warrant which is that's
what's mandated in our Constitution in
the way and and then they can conduct
surveillance on that individuals when
they suspect that's targeted
surveillance mass surveillance is when
they just collect information about
everybody all the time and that's not
that's not legal at least in our in our
Constitution but again if if the people
want to vote for it and and think that
that's right
that at least is is following democracy
and you know I I think that's that's
what should have happened in the United
States it's Christina German freelance
film journalist another German question
less Freudian it goes to Oliver Stone
you always do movies your way and you
never take the easy way and you never
sold out you never mellow down I would
like to know where you take the courage
and inspiration the balls if you like to
make movies your way and still always to
go against the grain
well in this case you it's just the way
I am
I don't like lies I feel very strongly
about lying government's do it and they
all do but the bigger the line more
dangerous and the United States case we
have a lot of line a lot of line has
been going on since World War two
especially about every war we're in we
get a false story being a false
narrative and our newspapers lead the
charge and each of these in charge we
another mess screw up more of the world
and just getting very messy now this is
the result so a lies hurt lies to me the
most dangerous thing in a society it
just were not informed we don't remember
citizenry does not inform all notions
it's an ideal situation let's have a
democracy but we should be informed if
we're gonna have a democracy they won't
trust us with anything everything is
national security now so the anger comes
from that you know my parents got
divorced when I was 16 I thought they
were a perfect couple
I found out afterward that there was a
lot of things going on behind the scenes
that were much more shocking and
realistic about life and you can say
that comes from there maybe who knows
but certainly you get lied to a lot as
an infant think about all the lives your
parents tell you Santa Claus thank God
so all I'm saying is that there's a
basic it's not about Vietnam is about
some fundamental lives of governments
keep telling it gets me a pissed off no
matter how old I am I think I still get
worked up I start talking back to the
newspaper when they sell me some build a
good sign then I heard the war and
before before they know is a lot so here
we are and that's what that's what
motivates me 1-1
thank you do you think you're ready yes
I just want to piss off great movie
thank you I saw it this morning and I
really enjoyed it today but do you think
the movie would have any effect for this
pardoned by the this president or maybe
the next president movies you know in
the United States it's funny the movies
barely comes out and already thinking on
news shows a pardon or no pardon hero or
traitor this is where they're jumping to
conclusions and no one in the audience
has seen the film so it's it's really
kind of self-defeating because we want
quick answers is the nature of our
society it's not plenty officers are not
the answer to be able to think we have
to pause breathe see the movie first and
then maybe you'll come to a different
conclusion about whether you should be
pardoned or at all so that's what I have
said my bad like this when I miss a
1970s antonioni kind of press
conferences when everybody broke out
calling out with no rules